moumoon
ni
It is the price that it was getting less and less and it's better to say to the elderly
The person who becomes is also a lever
true
It is said that the younger ones take care of me carefully and the cedars are not
I think that I do not have a job for younger people where I recommend
Hmm
Yup
Living here
It is fun to know that I already learned
I can not taste it in town
Japan also enjoys making lyrics, making fields, and making pottery again.
I am allowed to spend like that I'm making a scare here
After making it out, there are already hundreds of people who can meet various people.
I can meet people who can hear the stories of various towns
There is no one to say sad but sad
See you back again
Because it is said that it will be seen looking at the meaning in the heart because it was fun
This has come to people in various media countries
I want you to see it and think about it
Yup
me
Hmm
moon